it's the start of the third Act of the  movie and if I don't go catch that play  and then stop Veronica before she goes  to Cleveland you don't get that girl  you're the stupidest piece of human  excrement I've ever met in my entire  life I know I like do business now and I  just wear sweaters and I make money and  stuff like and that [ __ ] sucks I wish  you were dead I just want you to know  that you're my best friend I want to do  to you what they did to The Count of  Monte Cristo but without all the prison  escape thank you for the pep talk you  are classic although we're hard on each  other sometimes and although you're the  dumbest [ __ ] to ever set foot on Earth  I love you man I love you too man  anyways [ __ ] you as a man I don't like  saying nice things to you